in this Android tool time pro tip I'm
going to show you some Android studio
expert tips to keep you in the zone and
increase your productivity you're
probably already familiar with some of
the most common shortcuts turning on
automatic importing of unambiguous class
names
pressing shift twice to search
everywhere or using shift f6 to rename a
variable method or class so we'll skip
past those and try something a little
more nuanced than that here I need to
change the duplicated method to set
latitude I can bring up autocomplete to
make life easier with control space but
when I select the write method it
annoyingly inserts a new method in front
of the old one unless I hit tab instead
in which case it'll replace the old
method with the new one similarly if I
hit control shift space I get only
suggestions of the expected type and
after I make the selection hitting tab
will replace the old value for both
control space and control shift space
hitting the shortcut a second time will
suggest order completion options based
on change expressions collections lists
and arrays you will already know how to
navigate your code using the cursor keys
and using alt left and right to skip
across words and holding shift to select
them but did you know you can use alt up
to extend your selection to the next
containing node and all down to
correspondingly shrink your selection
once selected use alt shift up or down
to move the code use postfix code
completion to transform an already type
expression into another one such as
creating a for loop over a list or
turning an expression into an if
statement you can use command J to see
all the valid / fixes for a given
context for more complex patterns use
live templates to insert template add
code snippets for example using a
toaster shortcut makes it easy to add a
new toast where you only need to specify
the text to display there are dozens of
generic and android-specific live
templates including a selection of
blogging short cuts including log m that
inserts the current method name and the
name and value of each parameter passed
into it easier log statements are great
for debugging but did you know you can
also set conditional breakpoints that
can log the output of expressions
it's also possible to define a custom
rendering for objects while you're
evaluating expressions
rather than relying on their to string
values there are so many handy features
in Android studio that it's easy to
forget all their shortcuts luckily you
just need to remember one command shift
a and start typing keywords to find them
for example the structural search
feature lets you search for code
patterns without resorting to regular
expressions if you enable structural
search inspection and borrow a mouse you
can even provide warnings around methods
and syntax that you wish to discourage
within your code
similarly you can use the structural
replace feature to find and replace
deprecated code or common anti patterns
in do structural search inspection here
to offer a replacement snippet as a
quick fix option
there are hundreds of tips and tricks to
make your Android studio experience
faster more productive and mostly mouse
free subscribe to Android developers on
youtube and tune into Android tool time
for more Android tool time pro tips